[Applause]
[ __ ] okay let's do some
[ __ ] comedy serious
I love comedy but sometimes I wish I was
a painter because I've never been
painting a picture that the canvas be
like good publication being in Seattle I
love being able to look outside my
window and be like why should I try with
the day's uneven truck
very progressive town boys transitioning
here I saw a bicyclist so identified as
an automobile here I love it here cuz
I'm very gender fluid
I am biologically male but my bullies
identified me as a [ __ ]
I loved loved it here love women I have
a very straight man I think they're the
most beautiful gender that even race the
top 32 in my opinion I don't think I
could ever have sex with a dude I've
never looked at a beautiful woman and
they're like oh my gosh she is so
gorgeous but server Jennifer that's
bigger area has less tightness I like to
put that in my bottle I'm talking to
this guy who is also not gay is like
dude we're so lucky we're not gay in
your magic if most of the gender we were
attracted to wasn't attracted to his
back I was like wow I am single I have
to meet my soul mate and I begin to
think maybe it's her fault I should take
it out one she seems like a loser
I think we could do better I was talking
to this lady and she was like did you
know that my vagina is a duty printer
because I can make a baby I was like
that's not accurate your womb is a dirty
pension the Train
[Laughter]
it's not even a very good it'll imprison
one thing with lots of errors playing I
know what they look like but I'm not
that it's an anime which is unfortunate
because only white women were attracted
to me they're pretty damn I forgot that
interesting anime face
[Music]
constantly cosplay which is great
because I love going on dates with anime
fans and sometimes the end of a long day
I don't need a have sex you know sort of
rub noses with someone and pass out what
hands it's hard to date a destination
path you know analytics Asian women are
beautiful a lot of people think Asian
men are beautiful which doesn't even
make any sense
anything each of our gonna created me
[ __ ] I'm a crucial part of the sex
process please stop giving it got sex
with me our children that will be great
engineers and that's important the
racial thing going on in a race it's
pretty cool I'm not raising of course
without minority how could I be possible
I believe its secrets I only smell
I try not to be racist but of course
it's not always easy like I was on an
airplane and I saw a dude reading a book
in Arabic which kind of freaked me out
but that's not whole the corner of the
page and put it back in his bag and I
was like that guy's got future plans
I'm not races I'm a big fan of the Black
Panther movie eleganza great movie for
black children a hero they can come to
and not just hop on that Martin Luther
King jr. Malcolm X or Thurgood Marshall
your furniture a lot of people make
motivation it's because we eat dogs
which I understand to be very shocking
because in America dogs are treated like
family members but in Asia we treat our
family members like family members
a little custom we have there instead of
buying an animal we just love her
grandma
unless she's a baby girl which case you
throw the
[Applause]